in South Korea they're rehearsing
simulating the storming of a contested
Beach
waves of infantry with a direct Focus
defending the Peace of this peninsula
this sort of thing might be routine here
but it's the presence of their Partners
that's less so
and it's this presence that makes quite
the statement
it's been a while since the last time
we've done it but this is a routine
exercise it's defensive in nature and
it's just contributing to the combined
defense of the Korean peninsula
they're being careful with their words
but the message here spoke for itself
these drills had been paused amidst
attempts to negotiate with a
nuclear-armed North Korea but those
talks have failed and these exercises
are back for the first time in five
years the fact these drills are
happening again is Testament to just how
bad tensions on the Korean Peninsula
have become they've already listed a
response and will no doubt contribute to
the further deterioration in relations
there are those here who aren't happy
who see this as an escalation that makes
them less safe indeed North Korea sees
America's presence as particularly
provocative
it's responded by testing a barrage of
nuclear-capable missiles
but the government here says it's all
proportionate unnecessary and defensive
response
[Music]
in your view is North Korea going to
test another nuclear weapon
foreign
[Music]
Prospect of that test is the real worry
some sort of response would be hard to
avoid there is nothing new about the
threats faced here that there are
renewed attempts to deter them
Helena Smith Sky News in pohang South
Korea